I think when I was very young and
primary school I was taught by an
on-call sister Louise and I used to love
to write and sister Louise took my
little writings home and wrap them and
used to encourage me that yes you can
write you can do this and she gave me
the confidence to hit really know that
we're all given gifts and that's
important to develop and use those gifts
and I think every single one every
single person they've given a gift and
if you can find what it is and you come
to love it and enjoy it and appreciate
it and that helps make a difference to
the people around you and your community
so we're all special and we're all given
gifts and find your gift and enjoy it
have you enjoy life too